So, ich bin wieder da. Es kann sein, dass ich gleich noch mal kurz weg muss für 5 Minuten.
Wahrscheinlich reicht's, weil 5 Minuten sind sogar zu lang für ein paar Minuten.
Ich muss der Katze noch Medizin abreichen.
PHP, da kocke ich nicht, bei mir ist es ewig her.
Das letzte, was ich mit PHP gemacht habe, ist zu Battlefield 4 Zeiten so eine Profilpage für Leute, die auf meinem Server gespielt haben.
Und wann war Battlefield 4? 2012 oder so?
Ja, aber nix wildes, die hat Schilddrüsenprobleme.
Da muss man so eine Spritze aufziehen, das ist so Süßkram.
Also Spritze nicht zum Spritzen, sondern zum Ablecken.
Da muss man die auf den Arm nehmen und die Spritze in den Mund schieben und das dann verabreichen.
Aber glücklicherweise schmeckt das nicht so schlimm und die nimmt das ganz gut.
Ja, also, Leute, irgendwie bin ich ein bisschen müde, ich weiß auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Zu viel rumgegammelt heute den ganzen Tag.
Ich muss erstmal ein bisschen aufwachen irgendwie.
Ich hab nicht eben gepennt oder so, aber keine Ahnung.
Alles ein bisschen, wahrscheinlich ist es zu warm.
Nehmen wir die Klimaanlage an.
Nee, nee, nee, machen wir nicht.
Proc. Danke für den Sub.
Ich schmeiß schon mal meine 4M an.
Gut, dass wir heute Morgen schon alles geupdatet haben.
Das machen wir auch manchmal, aber selten, heute nicht.
Heute gucken wir uns PHP an.
Ich hab ewig nix mit PHP gemacht und zwar gucken wir uns heute das da an.
Wie gesagt, es wird nix super krass kompliziertes.
Wir machen ein Webservice, das das Kack W Bild rotiert.
Fertig.
Cack W S.
Irgendwie kann Google, findet das nicht.
Ja, ich kann hier Woblords GitHub machen.
Aber irgendwie findet das Google nicht, weiß auch nicht.
Ja, ich hab sowas vor Ewigkeiten schon mal gebaut in C-Sharp.
Das ist eigentlich so ein...
Wir machen kein wirkliches Frontend.
Wir machen ein paar API-Routen.
Ich guck, wie man Parameter übergeben kann.
Weil das ist heute tatsächlich mal ausnahmsweise was, wo ich im Vorfeld gar nichts,
wirklich gar nichts geguckt hab und auch keine Ahnung von hab.
Also das ist so eine Testanwendung, die ich für alle möglichen Sachen immer mal verwende.
Die haben wir beispielsweise auch immer benutzt, um irgendwelche Cloud-Services,
das Hosting von irgendwelchen Cloud-Services ausprobieren.
Die kann nichts, ja.
Die hat zwei Routen.
Einmal halt die Route.
Da wird ein Bild random gedreht.
Um 360 Grad.
Dann gibt es eine Route,
wo man ein Parameter mitgeben kann.
Äh...
Ne, einmal hier kann man ein Parameter mitgeben und hier gibt es das...
Hä?
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt gemacht hab.
Ach so!
Das eine ist...
Ne.
Das ist doch genau das Gleiche hier, oder?
Keine Ahnung, warum es das zweimal gibt.
Kein Schimmer.
So was bauen wir.
Das rufst du auf.
Dann sagst du Slash-Kick-W und kriegst ein Bild gedreht.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, das reicht mir schon mal heute, so was in PHP zu bauen.
Weil ich keine Ahnung von...
Okay, guck mal.
Das ist das PHP-Framework für Web-Artist...
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Ein Artist, oder wie?
Oder...
Was ist das?
Deutsch?
Handwerker!
Das ist ja ne...
Ich glaube, das haben sie sich früher auch schon so genannt.
Richtig agile Handwerker.
So.
Und das Ding ist, ich muss erst mal gucken, wie man das installiert.
Ja.
Vielleicht mach ich demnächst auch was mit Holz.
Man weiß ja nie.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir nur mal gucken, wie man das überhaupt installiert.
Ich hab...
Ich hab wirklich legit...
Ich hab absolut keinen Plan.
Guck mal mal.
Vielleicht gibt's hier schon was im Auer.
Im Arch.
By the way.
Ne.
Gibt es nicht.
CakePHP.
Ich weiß...
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, was das ist.
CakePHP versus Laravel.
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das einzige PHP-Framework, mit dem ich jemals was gemacht habe, ist Laravel.
Deswegen machen wir das damit jetzt auch.
Laravel muss über Composer ein NPM für PHP...
Oh ja, jetzt wird's immer besser, Alter.
Oh, nice.
Endlich.
Ich hab...
NPM reicht noch nicht.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch NPM für PHP.
Aber wir gucken uns das gleich mal an.
So.
Also.
Docker?
Getting started on Linux.
Ich brauch kein Docker dafür.
Sail up?
What?
If you're deploying on Linux and Docker Compose, you can use a simple terminal command to create
new Laravel...
Voll.
Warum brauch ich zum Teufel...
Warum brauch ich Docker?
Warum brauch ich Docker dafür?
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz rein, was da drin ist.
Ah, Docker stellt.
Okay.
Docker pull Laravel new.
Nein, nein.
Ich will einfach den Kram installieren.
Choosing your sales service.
Mein was?
Was wollt ihr von mir überhaupt?
Gibt's nicht irgendwie sowas wie How to install?
Es ist geil, dass in der gesamten Installationsanpackung...
Dass das in der gesamten Installationanleitung...
Nein, die machen...
Ah, Moment.
Hier ist es doch.
Okay.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Hier.
Hier ist es doch.
Composer braucht man.
Okay.
Yes.
Ich mach mal...
Leute, ich mach mal einen Snapshot.
Vielleicht muss ich diesen ganzen PHP-Exempel nachher wieder rückgängig machen.
Compo...
Compower.
Composer.
Da sind wir doch.
Ein Dependency Manager for PHP.
Jawoll.
Let's go.
Endlich PHP-Stellz wie 1995.
Auf geht's.
Gehen wir mal in meinen Temp-Ordner.
mkdir php keckel.
Okay.
Also, wie geht das jetzt?
Composer create projects Laravel slash Laravel.
Okay.
Warum auch immer.
Moment.
After you have installed...
Hab ich überhaupt PHP installiert?
Ja.
Hab ich.
Nice.
Warum hab ich PHP installiert?
Ah, weil Composer PHP mitbringt.
Okay.
After you have installed PHP and Composer, you may create a new Laravel...
Or you may create a new Laravel project by globally installing the Laravel...
Hä?
Ah.
Das ist quasi...
Das ist sowas wie npx.
Und das ist sowas wie npm install.
Und dann danach ausführen.
Okay.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das geht auch so.
Atheno, dankeschön.
Ich hab aber hier schon massig Trinkzeug.
Okay.
Example app.
kec w s service.
Npap.
Oh.
Nice.
Wie bei Javascript.
Das halbe Internet wird runtergeladen.
Ah, das ging aber schnell.
Also für Javascript-Verhältnisse ist das gar nicht mal so viel, glaube ich.
Schauen wir mal.
64 MB.
Da lacht sich ja jede Javascript-Anwendung drüber kaputt, Leute.
Wir haben noch letztens eine SvelteKit-Anwendung gemacht.
Moment.
SvelteKit-Anwendung.
Copypasta-Champ-Demo.
So, das zum Vergleich eine SvelteKit-Anwendung.
Kec.
Eine Demos-SvelteKit-Anwendung ist einfach 500 MB groß.
Javascript, man.
Okay.
Ups.
Kec-Javascript.
Wahrscheinlich die ganzen Logos aus der Lib.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich vermute...
Notmodules-Ordner.
Okay.
Temp.
Okay, wie geht's weiter?
Leute, wir brauchen jetzt erstmal...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Haben die nicht PHP-Champ?
Haben die nicht was für PHP?
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Webstorm?
PHP-Storm.
Warum sollte ich...
Warum sollte ich eigentlich PHP-Storm anstelle...
Warum gibt es überhaupt zwei...
Ach so, das eine ist die Javascript-Idee und das andere ist die PHP-Idee.
Okay, PHP-Storm.
Wow.
Das will schon nicht.
Guck mal, es wehrt sich schon.
Es widersetzt sich.
Es will kein PHP machen.
Gibt's sowas wie PHP-Web-Assembly?
Ohne Mist, ich hab nicht nachgeguckt, aber wahrscheinlich.
Ja, natürlich.
PHP im Browser.
Jawoll.
Da hab ich mein ganzes Leben lang drauf gewartet.
Endlich kann ich PHP kleinseitig verwenden.
Ich kann kleinseitige Anwendungen in PHP machen.
Yeah.
Nice.
Endlich.
Okay, PHP-Storm.
Da haben wir's.
So, also aber erstmal kurz gucken.
Wie geht's denn hier weiter?
KQ as a Service.
Okay, eine Sache ist schon mal...
Eine Sache haben sie schon mal sehr Javascript-mäßig sich abgeguckt.
Denn man hat erstmal 100.000 Dinger.
Ne Vite-Config hat man?
What the fuck?
Was ist denn hier alles?
What?
Niki C. ist auch am Start.
Tests.
Die kennen mich aber schlecht.
Wait, die haben standardmäßig schon Tests dabei.
What the fuck?
Was zum...
Was ist denn hier alles dabei?
Da blickt doch keiner durch.
Channel?
Console?
Inspire?
What?
Okay, das ist eine Demo-Anwendung.
Gibt es auch eine nackige, komplett...
Illuminati.
HTTP-Request.
Jetzt...
Jetzt steig ich aber schon aus.
Okay.
Also, wie führt man das aus?
PHP Artisan Service.
Okay, wir starten das jetzt mal.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Das ging schön schnell.
Da ist er.
Leute.
Das ist die Laravel-Demo-Anwendung.
Ja.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum der Javascript-Zeug dabei ist.
Weil die ein bisschen Frontend-Geduld haben.
Aber ich will ja eigentlich nur ein API-Projekt machen.
Gibt es...
Gibt es so ein Mini-Projekt?
Was Laravel...
Was...
Rees...
Authentication-Features?
Nein, nein.
Das ist ja noch mehr...
Ich will auch kein Login dafür haben.
Lachs gab es heute nicht.
Es gab heute...
Chat geht.
Nur weil ich 90% Samstag immer Nudeln mit Lachs futter,
esse ich nicht jeden Samstag Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute habe ich...
Ich kann euch sagen, was ich gefuttert habe.
Ich habe Reis gefuttert.
Mit so...
Fly...
Flying Goose Hot Sauce.
Und dann 3 Waffeln mit Blaubeeren drauf.
Richtig gesund.
Ne, beste ist das.
Flying Goose Hot Sauce.
Ne, das ist irgendwas anderes, Leute.
Das ist...
Goose not hot.
Oh, was ist hier unten los jetzt?
What?
Okay, das ist unsere Laravel-Demo-Anwendung.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal...
Alles...
Wir machen das jetzt mal in PHP-Storm auf.
PHP.
PHP-Storm.
Bam.
Premiere.
Noch nie hatte ich PHP-Storm auf.
Aber...
Das Gute ist...
Ich habe das JetBrains All-Inclusive-Desktop-Package.
Da ist PHP-Storm auch mit drin.
There was more than one class loaded.
This is likely a bug.
Das geht ja schon mal gut los.
Wir trusten.
Guck mal, es hat sogar einen Readme da drin.
Dass jeder Webspacestest kann...
Run npm install?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ah.
Was macht es?
Was macht es im Hintergrund?
Composer revert?
Ich klick das einfach mal alles zu.
Download pre-built shared indexes.
Ja, wunderbar.
Was auch immer.
App.
Kernel...
Alter, was ist das alles?
Ich will eine Hello-World-Anwendung.
Was ist...
Nee.
Das, das wieder...
Das, das...
Nee, das...
Ich bilde mir auch einen.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, vor Jahren was in Laravel gemacht.
Das war gar nicht so wild.
Da hast du drei Dateien gebraucht und gut ist.
Wann war BF4 Release-Date?
Hier.
Ja, so 2014 habe ich das mit Laravel gemacht.
Das war eigentlich total easy.
Aber das sah nicht so krass kompliziert aus wie hier.
What the...
Artisan PHP.
Was?
Okay, als erstes, Leute, ihr kennt mich.
Als erstes müssen wir erstmal...
Font einstellen.
Font-Size.
Ich bin noch nicht mal in der Lage...
...überhaupt zu finden.
Hier, Font.
JetBrains Mono.
Nein, nein, nein.
Hack.
18.
Ja, schon viel besser.
So, und wo stellt man in PHP-Storm jetzt das neue UI ein,
dass es halbwegs gescheit aussieht?
Colorscheme.
Haben wir einen Rider-Colorscheme?
Irgendwas, was gescheit aussieht?
Dark.
Ja, okay, schon besser.
Was?
Appearance.
Nothing here, okay.
Oh, was ist...
What the...
Was, don't show?
Was?
Okay.
Nothing here.
Theme.
Oh, meine Augen!
Nee, das Material-Theme mag ich nicht.
Appearance?
Ähm...
Nee, wo ist denn der Mist jetzt?
Appearance, hier.
Wo macht man das neue UI jetzt?
Da kann man das UI wechseln.
Ja...
Aber wo?
Ach, New UI.
Hier, Enable.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Restart.
Dann sieht das besser aus.
Kurz trinken.
Meet the new UI.
Ja, das ist doch schon gleich viel nicer.
Oh!
System.
Dark.
Clean, compact.
Naja, der Breite...
Wie macht man das überhaupt zu?
Okay, schon mal viel angenehmer.
Ernsthaft, Leute, was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Konfig.
Mail!
Was ist denn hier los, Mann?
Ich will keine Mails verschicken.
Ich will einfach nur zwei API-Endpunkte haben.
Yondiboy schreibt...
Nee, Yonderboy schreibt was?
Ach.
Ich wünsche, ich könnte auch JetBrains bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Wenn, dann haben wir nicht mal ein Git-Instrument.
Äh, warum kannst du es nicht verwenden?
Weil die es nicht kaufen wollen, oder was?
Oder weil du nichts installieren darfst?
There is battery included.
Das ist ja schön, wenn Batteries included sind,
aber warum gibt es die nicht?
aber warum gibt es für jede Batterie noch ein eigenes File?
Leute, ich glaube, wir brauchen ein anderes PHP-Framework.
Ich will einfach nur drei API-Endpunkte haben.
Fertig.
Und ich dachte, das ist mit Laravel easy,
weil ich habe vor zig Jahren mal was mit Laravel gemacht.
Auth.
Sanctum.
User.
Ich verstehe absolut nicht, was hier überhaupt vor sich geht.
Und nein, wir machen kein Raw-PHP.
Channels.
Console.
Ich habe wirklich absolut keinen Schimmer, was hier abgeht.
Okay, das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu oversized für meinen Zweck.
Ich wüsste noch nicht mal, wie ich API-Endpunkte mache.
Unter Roots kannst du...
Aber hier, API-PHP.
Hier kannst du API-Endpunkte für deine Application registrieren.
Diese Endpunkte werden von Root...
Okay, probieren wir das doch mal.
Root.
Middleware.
Auth.
Leute, ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Get.
Keg.
W.
Function.
Request.
Return.
User.
Lul.
So.
Jetzt führen wir das aus.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert, wenn ich auf die Route
slash keg w gehe.
Not found.
Middleware muss ich wegmachen.
Ich glaube, ich musste ein Tutorial lesen erst mal.
Get not found.
Und jetzt hier einfach...
Was?
Slash API?
Slash keg w?
Okay.
Wie gesagt, ich habe zuletzt was mit Laravel 2014 gemacht.
Da war das total easy, Routen und Sachen anzulegen.
Ach so, im Browser.
Also quasi...
API slash keg w.
Ah, guck mal da.
Root login not defined?
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube, Laravel ist wirklich für unseren Use Case echt krass oversized.
Laravel simple root.
Laravel create new application.
Was haben wir denn hier eigentlich gemacht?
Create project.
Ne, wir haben nur create project gemacht, sonst nix.
Das ist noch Laravel 4.
Ein PHP Framework.
How to create roots in Laravel.
Easy.
Okay.
Zeigt mal hier.
Easy.
Root...
Aha.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich relativ easy.
Ich will kein View return.
Ich will einfach...
Raw data return.
Okay.
Get return.
Ich will keinen View return.
Kann ich einfach irgendeinen String returnen oder sowas?
API slash keg w.
Ne, ne.
Nur keg w.
Installing Lumen.
Was zum Teufel ist denn jetzt Lumen schon wieder?
Ich sehe...
Lumen.
Auf jeden Fall eine Seite ohne Dark Mode.
Ich würde gerne mal wissen, was Lumen überhaupt ist.
Lumen has a few...
Und was ist das?
Okay.
Lumen.
Aha.
Lumen ist quasi so eine lightweight Laravel-Geschichte von Laravel.
Aber ist deprecated.
Ernsthaft?
Warum ist Lumen deprecated?
Okay.
Ja, das sollten wir schon mal nicht verwenden.
Aber ich wollte ja mal gucken.
Jetzt sollte es ja eigentlich eine keg w Route geben.
Ach ne, Moment.
API keg w.
Jawohl.
Easy.
Haben wir doch schon.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Ich würde sagen, done, oder?
Für heute.
Nice.
Ne.
Der Witz ist doch, dass ich was mit PHP machen will.
Wenn ich was mit irgendeiner anderen Sprache...
Das ist ja...
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Ich würde sagen, auf geht's.
Ja.
Senior PHP Developer.
Okay.
Das habe ich an der Stelle jetzt gecheckt, wie man Routen anlegt.
Die Frage ist, kann ich den ganzen anderen Campel löschen?
Ich brauche keine...
Okay.
Controller brauche ich.
Storage brauche ich nicht.
Keine Tests.
Das ist quasi meine Node-Modules, würde ich sagen.
Ich vermute aber, wenn ich die Ordner einfach lösche, dann ist broken.
Und was ist der App-Ordner?
App-Service-Provider?
Root-Service-Provider?
Slash...
Slash-Home?
What?
Okay, gut, dass es definiert ist.
Das ist geil.
Console-Kernel-PHP.
Also, Laravel macht mich echt...
Macht mich verrückt.
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich habe das 2014 mal verwendet.
Und da war das eigentlich relativ easy, dort Sachen drinnen anzulegen.
Aber das ist wirklich äußerst komp...
Ich meine, es geht.
Wenn man sich das mal anguckt, das ist ein bisschen was wie Ruby on Rails.
So ein bisschen ähnlich wie Ruby on Rails aufgebaut.
Bootstrap?
Ach, die App.
Singleton, Singleton?
Okay, die Sprache ist aus...
Illuminate?
Okay, wir bleiben bei der Minimal-Geschichte.
Wir bleiben bei der Minimal-Geschichte, ja?
Wir haben eine Route.
Slash-Cack-W.
So, und jetzt...
Und jetzt will ich...
Wie rotiere ich Bilder?
Also, okay, nee.
War was anderes.
Wie gebe ich jetzt hier...
Wie mache ich hier sowas wie...
Return-Pile-Dot-Open?
Nee.
Das kriege ich raus.
Also.
Cack-W.
Wir downloaden uns jetzt erstmal das Bild.
Wobei...
Wir müssen uns das Bild nicht runterladen.
Ich habe das doch hier irgendwo drinnen.
Äh.
Cack-W.
Es ist Service.
W-W-W-Root.
Ach, ich habe die Dinger sogar vorberechnet.
Nee, das müssen wir besser machen.
Okay, bestes, bestes Bild.
Copy-Image.
Public.
In Public kommt das wahrscheinlich rein.
CD.
Public.
Wget.
Äh.
Copy-Image-Link.
Passt mal auf.
Image.
Image-Cut.
Zack.
Schon haben wir das in der Konsole.
Das Beste.
Wichtig und richtig.
File-Get-Contents.
Ich sehe.
Der Chat hat Ahnung.
Aber ich muss sowas selbst rauskriegen.
Sonst...
Sonst ist es ziemlich...
Ziemlich pp-iger.
Ja.
Und jetzt muss ich gucken, wie ich Bilder rotieren kann.
Okay.
File-Get-Contents.
Ich vermute mal relativ zur Anwendung.
Image.
Public.
Cack-W.
PNG.
Ach ja.
Hat es Hot Reload?
Hat es sowas wie Hot Reload?
Oh.
Oh je.
Public.
Cack-W.
PNG.
Absolut.
Relativ.
Wie muss man das angeben?
Aber ich habe es relativ angegeben.
Es ist Public.
Sehen wir vielleicht, welche...
In welchem Verzeichnis wir sind.
PHP.
Print.
Current.
Factory.
Get-CWD.
Alles klar.
Noch besser.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
In welchem Verzeichnis sind wir?
Ach, wir sind schon in Public.
Ach so.
Ja dann.
Ease.
Dann ist es einfach nur Cack-W.
PNG.
Aber da muss ich bestimmt Mimetype und sowas angeben.
Das ist ja nicht als Image, sondern als Binary-Zeug.
Wie macht man das?
File-Get.
Das sind wahrscheinlich Bytes.
Ach so.
Ja.
Moment.
Wie macht man Variablen?
Ich bin komplett planlos.
File-Responses.
Excellent.
Chat.
Ah.
Aha.
Okay.
Return.
Response.
Make.
File-Responses.
Response.
Ach so.
So einfach so.
Return.
Response.
File.
Path.
Headers.
Okay.
Ups.
Was jetzt?
Das hat.
Okay.
Return.
Und eine Variable ist einfach so.
Bytes.
Ja.
Okay.
Return.
Response.
File.
Cack-W.
PNG.
Einfach so.
Easy.
So.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Weil.
Kann man hier auch Bytes.
Kann man hier auch Bytes übergeben?
Muss man gucken.
Nein.
Response.
Ich mein.
Ich.
Ich muss dem Ding.
Make.
Vielleicht.
Warum macht man freiwillig PHP?
Weil ich einfach mal wieder PHP angucken wollte.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Die Sache ist die.
Ich glaube.
Also ich muss jetzt.
Also normalerweise muss man folgendes machen.
Man muss ja Response anlegen.
Man muss den MIME-Type festlegen.
Also was ich angucken will.
Ich glaube.
Also ich muss jetzt.
Also normalerweise muss man folgendes machen.
Man muss ja Response anlegen.
Man muss den MIME-Type festlegen.
Also was ich angucken will.
Also was ich application.json.
In dem Fall ist es image.png.
Und.
Muss ich irgendwie Header hinzufügen.
Für.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Stream.
JSON-Responses.
Response.
JSON.
New responses.
Laravel.
Response.
Content-Type.
Ja.
Aber das kann doch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein.
Da ich das selbst von Hand angeben muss.
Oder?
Ja.
Na.
Nacheinander.
Next-Tab.
Land.
Stimm mainten.
Duty.
Speed 1.
Qualität.
Ja.
array status header ja ja das sieht gut aus okay contents bytes status 200 ist
okay headers
level response make image png wie macht man sowas ja method to use response
stream ach ja sehr schön ne Moment das will ich nicht aber ich kann auch
bestimmt auch streamen nicht vom file sondern von einem byte array oder sowas
okay response stream response make und dann file 200 und dann sagt man content
type image png okay dann ist es tatsächlich relativ easy also sag mal
einfach so response make return response oder oder Moment make ist das dann so
unnecessary local ja ja und jetzt response header content type muss man das
großschreiben content type und ich glaube es ist image png ich bin mir da
nicht ganz ganz sicher ich glaube ist es image png
ich glaube schon okay testen wir mal jawohl easy so und jetzt wird es
kompliziert jetzt müssen wir das image rotieren irgendwie in php php rotate png
image rotate jetzt jetzt wow image rotate rotate an image with a given
angle ice fleet dankeschön für den sattel danke für die anderen subs die ich
vielleicht übersehen habe ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was ich so eine
aufwachen ist das ach so hast du die moment siehst du die emotes nicht so
sollte das emote eigentlich bei dir aussehen wenn du bei dir die emotes
nicht siehst dann brauchst du ffz oder bei der twitch tv oder 7 tv image
rotate image rotate das kann man einfach inkluden
xgd ist missing was ist was ist xgd ok ich brauche image rotate how to rotate
easy guides composer create composer require inter intervention
alter was ist das hier 360 no scope was ist was ist intervention image ist es
eine image library was anderes wie die die ok was ist was ist besser standard
library oder oder intervention ok dann machen wir das doch mal komposer
require intervention was es macht ernst hab ich einen sündags check glaub es
nicht ok so als das ist installiert und weiter
konfig app oh what what oh leute ich muss kurz ich muss kurz der katze
medikamente verabreichen ich bin ich bin gleich wieder ich bin
gleich wieder da zwei minuten
ist wieder am start heute hat sich gewährt die wollte ihr zeug dich futtern
alles da hier steht wie man das wie man das macht ok basic basic image make
open an image weil neue able to resize the instance inside watermark also
sprich image make gucken ob das meiner meinen php krempel hier und die fein
klasse image wahrscheinlich muss ich das noch irgendwie in level integrieren
das label i require that least and concert per read about level integration
ok
after you have installed image open your level config file at the following
lines in the providers array ok machen wir ich habe keine ahnung was ich da
mache aber ich mache das jetzt einfach mal im providers im providers array das
dahin zu fügen intervention 360 no scope alles klar
and the facade of this in the alias array ich habe keine ich habe wirklich
absolut keine ahnung was da mache aber ok also ich habe es gar nicht gestartet so
und jetzt und jetzt kann man image verwenden das habe ich ja gerade gemacht
das braucht es da stand doch dass ich das nicht brauche im port der image
manager class aber ich habe immer noch kein image jetzt ist die gd library
extension not available with this php installation also jetzt brauche ich php
gd alles klar easy einfach nach installieren so
next gd library extension not available with this php installation
alter
ok was php gd ist eine extension in der php ini sein muss wie jetzt ich habe
das schon installiert im guck php ini was wo ist denn meine php ini das kann
es doch nicht sein das muss auch ohne in etc moment ich muss ich muss für eine
für zum anwendungsentwicklung in einem verzeichnen wo ich noch gut rechner
hab rumwursten
webserver noch ich bin ich habe keinen webserver laufen ich habe den standard
eingebauten webserver nene das muss anders gehen
wo aktiviert man das artisan surf php gd ich muss wirklich in etc was machen ja
und jetzt ja so und jetzt und jetzt surf image source not readable ok ok wir
kommen der sache näher wir kommen der sache näher wie man kann die nicht
standardmäßig einen aus kommentieren mit der schmitt im standard shortcut was
sind das ok keck weh keck keck weh png gucken wir mal ob das ob das funktioniert
so header content type image das wird was eigentlich so nicht funktionieren
oder in die beiz oder dollar image
image ich greife ich denn jetzt da auf irgendwelche sachen zu aber warum habe
ich ihn keine aus und komplett dafür jetzt was ist das an die fein klar es
stimmt doch überhaupt nicht muss ich das reloaden weg damit pp storm aber
neu aufmachen weil projekts ich mache das jetzt noch mal neu auf tmp php das
window import class intervention image so muss man das machen non static method
make should not be called statically aber das sagt die doku selbst dass man das
machen soll make aha und jetzt bei jetzt irgendwie gibt es gibt es dabei jetzt von
oder kann man oder kann man das jetzt einfach hierhin hier rein schieben
anscheinend wie auch immer das jetzt die typkonvertierung macht keine ahnung
kalt und die fein method warum ist das an die fein an die fein method welche
make aber aber moment die sagen doch selbst dass es so geht
ach nee moment konfigure with favorite image driver neben bei default image
make mache ich doch mache ich mache ich doch neu image ich habe so keine ahnung
was ich hier überhaupt machen integration ja das mache ich doch
example ja angeblich soll das einfach funktionieren ohne irgendwas guck hier
was ist das bei by default intervention image uses if you want to switch schnell
ich muss gar nichts angeblich muss ich nur also integration level is easy as
fuck man muss man muss diese zwei sachen hinzufügen und das war es mehr muss man
mehr muss man nicht machen sagt sagt das geht aber nicht ja aber ich habe ja schon
alles importiert was man importieren muss guck hier im port im port intervention image
als der falsche import ist das richtig ach das ist richtig ja okay da muss man erst mal
drauf kommen ja gut das ist klar png return image response vom das sollte es doch eigentlich
selbst wissen oder da ist es nice das hat funktioniert und es hat vorher resized easy
hat funktioniert okay rotate image rotate um keine ahnung 40 grad so easy
so w ist rotatet und jetzt die frage random in php random php rand rand in
was sind da jetzt der unterschied rand ok random in versus rand spb random in
crypto kräftig ist das brauche ich nicht das ist mir egal ob das crypto kräftig crypto
secure ist ok rand min ok von 0 bis 360 nee von 1 bis 360 weil ist das inklusive oder
exclusive if call it min arguments inclusive ok also brauche ich brauche ich 1 und 360 grad
ok war hier besser besser namen überhaupt jetzt ok einmal einmal eine random nummer
rotaten um dollar e please das funktioniert leute random rotation ist am start tag ws
service alive was ist jetzt habe ich mich jetzt gebannt man kann sich mit local host
request bannen wirklich ja und wie entbahn ich mich wieder fixing to many requests hier
middleware groups if you open in php ok ok ok moment wo muss ich hin ab hat er war doch
richtig ab php können php das gleiche körnel middleware groups api und was rotteln ja wie
jetzt middleware groups middleware groups ja du willst sie throttle api sehe ich nicht
aber wir wissen jetzt wir wissen jetzt zumindest schon mal wie das heißt reddit reddit was
das ist es wahrscheinlich nicht da sind irgendwelche options hintendran 60 und 1
da muss ich doch nix hinten angeben oder doch muss ich da irgendwas hinten ich weiß ernsthaft
nicht wie das geht ok 10 throttle vielleicht kann man das vielleicht genau vielleicht kann
man es einfach aus kommentieren das ist natürlich auch noch eine idee easy einfach
auskommentiert wer braucht denn sowas auch schon also php ist wirklich so nicht meine erste wahl
was was websachen angeht für klinisch der vorteil ist halt es läuft überall ok jetzt werde ich
auch nicht mehr gefragt hat python läuft auch überall müde jemand billigen billiges billiges
web hosting und versucht da mal peinchen laufen zu lassen ganz vergessen du kannst vielleicht mit
python static side generator machen oder so aber sicherlich nichts dass darauf laufen lassen ok
also anscheinend bin ich mir geflottet sehr schön hätten wir das schon mal so ok und jetzt kommt als
nächstes ein parameter ja nene auflösung nicht unbedingt parameter brauchen wir aber wir brauchen
noch ein parameter für also das ist jetzt ja random random wie das rotiert wird was wir brauchen was
wir jetzt noch brauchen ist wir brauchen nicht random rotatet sondern wir brauchen die gleiche
sache noch mal ob eine wie mache ich ihn hier wie mache ich hier parameter also in
c sharp würde ich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht sowas probieren aber hier
root get parameter root parameter root parameter assist mal ich lag gar nicht so
verkehrt machen wir mal wirklich sowas hier er id ist es ja nicht wirklich ich glaube wir
brauchen wirklich zwei ruten da wir brauchen einmal so eine und dann brauchen wir noch eine
für enge rotation und wie greife ich da jetzt drauf zu a function string id function und hier
machen wir jetzt in so ne das ist falsch dollar dollar enge ok dann machen wir nämlich den
random shit raus so das müsste jetzt eigentlich schon gehen passt mal auf keck 1 das funktioniert
220 funst easy 340 ja gut wir sollten noch mal wir sollten uns noch mal ein bisschen was angucken
ich meine eigentlich ist es egal der rotiert ja dann einfach weiter aber wir könnten mal
gucken wie man eine exception wirft oder einen error code wirft mit php if enge
schauen wir größer 360 oder enge kleiner 1 dann return response so wie macht man jetzt
hier wir machen hier einen error oder kann man hier einfach den code übergeben ach hier kann
man einfach sagen status ne hecke status code 900 ich weiß gar nicht ob es http 900 gibt
status code 900 ist not valid http 900 gibt es das überhaupt moment tatsächlich 413 ja
beste 418 wie jetzt content ist keckel ja okay es funktioniert halbwegs ja also wenn man wenn
man misst angibt so zum beispiel 0 oder sowas dann geht es nicht wenn man ordentlichen engel
angibt dann dann klappt das irgendwie 90 90 180 360 ja mal gucken wie das mit punkten ist ich
glaube nicht dass das so unescape moment das geht aber das ist ein int warum kann ich kommers den
ins machen ach der schneidet einfach den hinteren teil ab pass mal auf warum sollte man das eigentlich
nur ins machen das wird jetzt einfach ein float wie sie ändert sich da was weiß nicht so und
jetzt müssen wir natürlich mal was checken wie macht man einen console console out php
auto lock to console in php ja ja nein nicht die konsole nein nein nein nein ja serverseitig
im float die back to konz was nein php hat keine konsole max wieso hier ist auch eindeutig was php
lock string jetzt muss ein php erlogge auto print die backlog was log error standard out logging
to standardout log use files jetzt ernsthaft du kannst nicht einfach konsolen ausgaben in php
ohne weiteres machen der lehrer will log alert ok log geht nicht aber das muss ich erst mal
importieren muss erst mal importieren import class ja wohl nee das ist das falsche was
ich importiert habe das gibt es nicht das ist richtig das ist aber doch die image library
warum sollte ich mit der image library loggen ach nee inter intervention ist die image library
illuminate ist ist lehrer will alert ok keck wait message ok gibt er jetzt was aus nö
da gibt nichts aus und man schreibt jetzt etwa log files und wo schreibt er die log files hin
storage logs ich will es einfach öffnen wie sagt man ist das man muss doch in
man muss doch in der welt lock auf die konsole rausschreiben können du suchst
dampf ok dampf so ich das bin ich mir nicht sicher nee so ich wahrscheinlich nicht also
log standard out das muss doch funktionieren logging to standard aus
es ist doch jetzt nicht euer ernst ich mein
konsole
php ist legacy es fakt das stimmt überhaupt nicht lehrer will und php wird weiterhin
aktiv entwickelt das ist so wie wenn du sagen würdest t plus plus ist legacy es
fakt wobei echo ok was brennt f ok ihr seid jetzt chat exzellent
jetzt sogar kaputt bringt er hat es zerstört aber es muss doch möglich sein system echo
es muss doch möglich sein es ist muss doch log use files dann ok dann probieren wir das
mal so wie der typ das hier macht und jetzt uses files was macht es ist not found ja super
nice application ja ganz bestimmt you can also copy the standard item vom konfig logging
ok konfig logging standard error aber es will ich doch gar nicht das will ich doch gar nicht
ich will nicht alles ich will einfach nur eine console right line machen das kann doch nicht
sein dass ich in php kein normales console right line also ich meine nicht im browser
php print standard out so was ne standard output 0w alter wie kann das sein ich copy
paste jetzt einfach sinnloses zeug guckt bis es geht chat ihr habt schon verstanden was ich
machen will oder battleship hat es aber nicht verstanden du hast ein grundlegendes missverständnis
wie php funktioniert ok also er sagt das läuft hier auf meiner kiste und hat hier einen hat hier
ein offi output auf der konsole da muss ich doch was selbst in diesen output rein kriegen das ist
freuen uns alle machen mach ein dampf und was dd was ist dd dd das kommt das ist so so wird das
hat noch nicht mal das hat noch nicht mal hilfe text keine ahnung was auch immer also ich bin
noch nicht mal in der lage einen output zu machen auf der auf der konsole und ich scheine ich der
einzige sein das problem hat es gibt es gibt einfach kein console output logging ich mein
immerhin immerhin kann ich meine bilder rotieren ja krasse krasse w rotation das ist schön wenn
ich sie dort net anwendungen starten da kommt ihr auch vom webserver aber ich kann trotzdem
console right line machen hol dir die debug bei ja das kann ich im browser machen aber warum kann
ich nicht ein stinknormales console right line machen in php das ist zu dass es nicht nicht
im scope wie es aussieht gibt es nicht in der logging php da bin ich doch gerade schon in der
logging php müsste der default driver default driver ja lock channel hast du dich eben gerade
um 90 grad rotatet doch ja sowas wie die bar clock gibt es ja da anscheinend nicht oder
tatsächlich was macht das jetzt die bar clock wie verwendet man das überhaupt nee das ist dass
das geht wieder ins log log file ok keine ahnung ich gebe es auf wir machen keinen
standard output wir machen keinen schon das geht aber ins log file das das geht nicht das
geht nicht auf die standard ausstatt standard out so ok dann lassen wir das jetzt dann verlassen
wir machen wir machen keinen wir machen keinen output mit php also haben wir jetzt die meist
jetzt haben wir jetzt wenigstens unsere ganzen features nach features das überhaupt schon zu
nennen chat gpt ne fragt mal chat gpt ich bin gerade nicht eingeloggt also mehr kann meine
beispielanwendung in dort net auch nicht rotaten und rotaten mit parameter ok so und wie bandele ich
das jetzt oder gar nicht ich würde ich würde einfach das ding 1 zu 1 auf den webserver hoch
schieben und dann dann geht es einfach das ist er log ne ne ne das wird das wird auch nicht
funktionieren oder ausprobieren ok was macht das warum gibt es tausend tausend sachen zum
warum ist es so kompliziert warum findet man das in den ersten paar google dinger nicht gibt es
da auch noch irgendein gegenstück zu hauptsache er macht den warning hast du rechts mir gar nicht
aufgefallen was ist das gegenstück zu error log gibt es auch so was wie einfach nur log
ne ne das ist okay das war noch mal wieder was ganz was anderes one log warning log es gibt
nur error log aber okay wir kriegen immerhin immerhin ging wir standart auch schon mal was
raus bin ich bin ja schon mal begeistert ja oder die debug debug log ne gibt es auch nicht
into a file ne ich will sie ok das leute damit gebe ich mich zufrieden damit gebe ich mich
zufrieden es ist egal das steht ein warning davor hauptsache ich kann irgendwas auf
standart standart outloggen wenn auch auf sehr wirre art und weise ach man kann hier
sogar den error typen wir haben wir nicht es ist deprecated
was ist deprecated moment das ist deprecated das hier nicht
string message in message type ok message type says where the arrow should go possible
values are system logger mail no longer an option ne ne das bringt ja nix ich will es
ist immer ein error auf jeden fall ja aber das ist schon mal ok wenigstens wenigstens
weiß ich jetzt wie ich wie ich sachen auf der auf der kommandozeile logge bin begeistert
probier mal trigger error php just oh okay man kann den trigger er war ernsthaft was normales
eintragen message error level notice jetzt jetzt macht passiert gar nix user warning
am moment ach hier haut er das jetzt raus das haut er jetzt hier in der error in der
error fehlermeldung ach so okay ja nee das will ich ja nicht ich will ich will auf der auf der
konsole loggen aber das ist auch schon mal gut zu wissen mit trigger error kann man quasi hier in
dem in dem frontends ok also es gibt es gibt error log fertig mehr gibt es anscheinend nicht
error log kek weh sehr schön wunderbar ok nice ich würde sagen da haben wir kek weh as a service
erfolgreich in level umgesetzt ich würde sagen wir gucken uns jetzt mal an was es noch für andere
nice php frameworks gibt weil ich habe heute noch nicht genug von php ich fand das so geil wir
brauchen unbedingt noch mehr php sachen okay awesome php jawohl beste frameworks micro
frameworks level 0 das wird ja nicht mal weiterentwickelt oder doch console applications
wer ist denn so massuschistisch veranlagt und macht konsolenanwendung mit php was hip hop php
php code ist translated zu c++ also irgendwann nehmen ja die ab die abscheulichkeiten auch kein
ende mehr oder was php das jp ap framework github fast secure and professional achmet
hat committed auf geht's php framework das ist doch bestimmt von yahoo oder sowas ich will mal
kurz gucken was ist denn micro framework mit radar silly slim wie das aussieht man
gekommen hat es am start ok sehr beliebtes framework massive beliebtes framework geupdated
framework was auch immer alter netzent kenne ich noch von früher das war richtig abartig cake php
getting started ok ich glaube das ist das ist ja auch relativ beliebt oder jetzt geht's ab
leute rapid development in php das gucken wir uns jetzt auch noch an wir machen wir genau die
gleiche anwendung jetzt noch in cake php die anwendung selber ist ja easy ok getting started
installation if you prefer gibt es jemand ernsthaft der die es präfert install composer
haben wir wir haben composer composer create project prefer dist cake php ist es die aktuelle
version 4 warum ist das sowas hasse ich immer wenn die anleitung schon outdated sind moment
ich habe nichts gesagt die google suche ist einfach nur pp ok ist gut ja ich hab's hab's
installation ernsthaft die machen jetzt komplett ein auf backen und was heißt wie heißt denn das
published command bake oder mkd cake as a service ok mal gucken ob das jetzt ein bisschen weniger
hat ich war mal hier php storm bam trust wir trasten das window ok php cake application
skeleton installation haben wir gemacht aber das gemacht ja aber gemacht if you want to
customize bin cake server was was you must enable the intel extension to use in home
requirements php ok intel und wie mache ich das jetzt geht nicht wenn du amd hast
you must enable the intel extension habe ich doch ich habe den kram nicht installiert php
intel wie installierst du ein php intel auch mit auch mit composer you can remove das extension
ist not loaded ok wie fixe ich das man muss tatsächlich php intel installieren php ok
was jetzt was no such online 5 ist es ja wahrscheinlich fehlt das package ist das
package aber welches davon ist das richtige die drei php 56 funktioniert alles richtig gut
install php intel abt install ok arch das muss ich glaube man muss das wirklich exklusiv in
docker container benutzen sonst kannst du es klicken aber das ist doch schon da steht
provides php intel das müsste eigentlich schon dabei sein warum kannst du auf der
arbeit nicht googeln ok keine ahnung gibt es sowas wie system ctl restart php ich meine
nix was da im hintergrund läuft da man weiß ja man weiß ja nie ja ne php gibt es ja aber ist
dabei weil alles selbst gebaut ist bei euch wir nutzen nicht mal geht das erscheint mir
allerdings nicht sonderlich effektiv zu sein was da passiert was php minus m less intel
ja macht also das ist geladen anscheinend aber aus irgendwelchen gründen geht es nicht muss
ich das vielleicht muss ich das vielleicht gar nicht hier hier hin zufügen jetzt ist es nicht
drin nice funktioniert ja richtig gut also ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was ich jetzt
machen muss dass das funktioniert halt opening required keck wehwender autoload in
was willst du überhaupt von mir man autoload php die gibt es gar nicht die datei gibt es
gar nicht das ist das demo projekt ok noch mal noch mal die anleitung kurz kurz checken
habe ich gemacht genau so ok wir waren es noch mal rückgängig er m composer create project
würdest du deine c++ oder eine php erfahrung höher raten dass er mich vorhin nicht gefragt
meine c++ erfahrung bin jetzt geht's ich habe keine ahnung warum einfach das projekt
noch mal neu gemacht ok jetzt geht's 8765 database driver mysql ich leute alter was
ist das wer hat sich das ausgedacht mit php man ich will keine datenbank haben defaultmäßig lasst
mich doch einfach in ruhe man ich will ich will stink normal ich will zwei apn punkte haben ohne
datenbank ohne irgendwas man ich brauche nicht war php slim ja das habe ich gehört das habe ich
schon gesehen aber was mich an slim ein bisschen abschreckt ich meine das hat oh ich habe mich
verguckt ich habe eben was gesehen das hatte 80 80 11k sterne ja das ist gut das will ich haben
slim slim framework slim as a php micro framework das helps you create right simple yet powerful
web applications and apis ja das will ich haben genau user guide getting started installation
install composer install slim install psr 7 nie holen ps was soll ich installieren gassel
psr 7 was ist psr 7 dass ein webserver ist das absicht dass er den php tag nie beendet das
macht man so okay okay also dann weg damit so jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt die minimal geschichte
composer require slim ist slim überhaupt das richtige slim github die richtige version 4
ja okay da sind wir so php storm wir trasten alles klar richtige trusters am start
wenn du gibt nix so ich gehe mal davon aus das hat er schon gemacht psr gedöns ich ich mache
jetzt einfach mal das hier weiß ich genau ist das ein webserver ich weiß nicht genau was psr 7 sein
soll okay und jetzt machen wir public index php okay new folder public index php auf geht's
hello world und wie führe ich das jetzt aus einfach php punkt oder sowas nee slim ja so
how to run the application wäre schon mal ganz spannend also okay php how to run slim first
application walkthrough das ist noch drei ja haben wir gemacht public index php hier ja sowas
wäre schon mal ganz schön zu wissen localhost port 8080 no resource found moment wo muss ich
das ausführen im public hallo da sind wir easy sehr schön nice kann man jetzt okay ich glaube
hier kann man jetzt auch ganz normales console log oder sowas machen slim console log log
standort okay das ist jetzt hier auch nicht so einfach wie man sich das vorstellt okay logging
scheint in p also sachen auf standard out zu schreiben ist nicht im scope bei vielen php
sachen anscheinend so okay weiter das sieht ja relativ das sieht ja relativ simpel aus ja okay
get slash function sondern machen wir noch mal was hier get keck weh function request response
arcs wunderbar ja das ist das eine jetzt ist natürlich nur die preisfrage wie kriege ich
was hin was ein parameter hat slim api parameter slim parameters genau hier get books damit
doppelpunkt und dann fangt schon ha echo okay keck weh angle rotation und warum geht das jetzt
das ging doch eben auch was ist das für eine php version was php 56 wir haben 82 was auch
immer dass da wieder erkannt hat wir haben 82 wir haben nicht php so und jetzt hier response
okay das body right einfach so was hier ach nee sowas hier dann hoffe ich mal aber auto
real outfits nicht haben keck keck weh nee okay anscheinend macht man so doch keine routen hätte
ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht geht dann geht dann das hier mit slash keck weh das geht ich hatte
die part 2 moment auf 4 0 parameter parameter request parameter ja schon parameter ja mensch
so kompliziert kann es doch nicht sein ich will kein pock ich will aus der route was haben also
quasi sowas hier also quasi ich sehe da nix post how to get request object du musst den body holen
und dann warum ist das so eklig alles nee ja sowas id warum ist da so eine random klammer
hinten ab als optional ist ok rotation also im prinzip ok moment mal was noch mal hier sowas
will ich haben ok das funktioniert warum warum kein lehrer will haben wir doch ganz am anfang
gemacht response ok so und jetzt mit arcs oder wie warum gibt es nicht einfach jetzt so was
wie rotation oder so was war was mache ich jetzt mit arcs explode muss ich jetzt so machen dollar
arcs rotation sowas ok moment ich habe ja ich habe ja was gelernt aber hier geht das ja ok so
geht das ja ist ein bisschen umständlich aber aber ok ok ja alles klar ja das schon mal nicht
verkehrt so und jetzt noch mal image image rotation das wissen wir ja wie das geht mit
dem image rotation das können wir uns hier das können wir uns hier raus raussaugen wo war das
jetzt noch mal drunter ja ich habe kein mit mit console support aber das ist auch nicht weiter
wild hier image make ich brauche jetzt mal image ich muss den kram erst mal installieren ich muss
den kram erst mal ins installieren hier composer wie ist das intervention ok image am moment
falscher ordner inter und auch nicht in public sondern hier require intervention image ja ja
image da sind wir doch image das ist das müssen wir das importieren importieren das da ist das
richtige das habe ich jetzt gelernt so und das war es make keck w.png so das bild habe ich noch
nicht das heißt er wird mir jetzt sagen was moment bis hierhin hat es eben doch noch funktioniert
ich bin im falschen ordner public ok oh oh oh was jetzt an caught error das ist ja schlimmer als
java fehlermeldung was ist das problem das bild gibt es nicht aber wo steht das nee class not
found class not found ok but why das package ist level specific nee ist es nicht wie kommst
du da drauf windows da gehe ich bestimmt darauf auf diese seite da unten die da unten verlinkt
ist also ganz ehrlich ich komme mir verarscht vor von php das ist ja maximal unverständlich
also mein sogar meine idee erkennt dass ich installiert habe aber php selber sagt das gibt
es nicht ja gut mein php sucht das auch nicht aber wie würde ich ihm sagen dass das sucht
ok slim rotate image ich habe keinen bock mehr leute hier nervt mich mehr mehr fertig kein php
mehr reicht mir kein php scheiß drauf snapshot weg weg mit allem php was wir heute gemacht haben
sagt jetzt spring boot jetzt noch ja war hinten drauf ja mal ganz davon abgesehen ich glaube spring
boot ist tatsächlich ganz nice alles was ich bisher von gehört habe nicht dass ich mich jetzt
mit java beschäftigen will grpc mit go nee wenn schon wenn schon die coolen leute machen ja auch
gar kein grpc mehr die coolen leute machen tt rpc oder sowas wie das heißt das geht aber natürlich
nur mit no gs ich glaube ich glaube für asp.net gibt es da noch nix das ist jetzt rast nein ich
mache jetzt kein rast ich mache jetzt auch kein spring boot war auch kein peißen mit janko ich
mache auch kein kräftel oder sonst was heute war php so und php hat mir nicht gefallen das wird es
gewesen sein ja hätten wir das mal alles richtig agile im container workload deployed wäre alles
gut gewesen brainfuck kurz die klimaanlage ausschalten die kühl das hat mich echt genervt
jetzt also ich ich kann mir vorstellen wenn man ein bisschen php macht ist es irgendwann erträglich
aber wirklich schön chat ich habe ja mitbekommen es sind einige von euch am start die php machen
gibt es jemand von euch der php wirklich gerne macht oder ihr macht halt einfach nur php weil
halt weil ihr php anwendungen betreut macht jemand von euch wirklich gerne php man hat so viele
wunderbar sonderheiten ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das ein vorteil ist okay wir haben wir haben ein paar
php enjoyer heute nur noch sie schreibt ja ich also ganz ehrlich asp.net core ist so ein angenehmes
framework ich wüsste auch gar nicht warum ich sachen in php machen sollte das einzige was ich
mir vorstellen könnte es ist wirklich wenn ich es auf irgend so einem billig web hosting gedöns
laufen lassen will andernfalls irgendeine billige vm im internet kannst du
alles drauf laufen lassen was du willst also insofern eigentlich gibt es nicht wirklich
ein grund ist in php zu machen das war schon echt eklig ja cloud run kannst du auch alles
laufen das brauchst du nur eine container image viel e-commerce läuft mit php ja ich weiß das
liegt das liegt aber glaube ich genau an diesen kunden du kannst es auf jedem haus da laufen
lassen und diese software ist meistens ja auch schon uralt oder man nimmt sowas als ss service
sowas wie shopify dann musst du dich mit sowas überhaupt nicht mehr beschäftigen schrieb wurde
mal kurz das ganze php shit weg ist wobei ich habe mein snapshot restaurant eigentlich muss
ich gar nicht geboten ein kleines snapshot gleich wieder löschen sonst vergesse ich übrigens ich
habe gelesen wir haben uns noch letztens überlegt ob wir nicht mal testweise bei der oracle cloud
uns angucken sollten ob die ob die kostenlose vm was taugt weil die haben ja immerhin glaube ich
eine vier kerne vm mit mit irgendwie keine ahnung 4g ram oder so kostenlos und ich habe letztens
gelesen dass oracle mal ganz gerne einfach accounts terminiert ohne einen kund zu nennen obwohl die
das fried hier nicht überschreiten also typische typische oracle schrott mal wieder der hintergrund
passt nicht so wirklich gut oder ob es falscher wir hatten wir haben den passenden hintergrund
dafür wir haben es gibt es gibt ja extra ein für php den hier müssten wir jetzt eigentlich nehmen
wettke php hat php wirklich so ein elefant als maskottchen dachte ich dachte das ist postgres mit
dem elefant ach tatsächlich ok postgres maskottchen ach nee das sieht anders aus da muss ich sagen
da sieht der php elefant aber deutlich netter aus der php elefant erinnert mich ein bisschen an
sendung mit der maus elefant so ein bisschen aber der postgres elefant der stinkt dagegen ab der
sieht nicht so nice aus slonik heißt ja der postgres elefant sowieso kommt es gibt sogar
einen kappa breit php elefant als hyper gachi immerhin hat php den spaceship operator das
ist in der spaceship operator das ding und was macht der spaceship operator wofür ist
das spaceship operator da kleiner und größer aber nicht gleich oder wie oder null plan davon
habe der slide wenn ich per oracle cloud free tier ein eigenes vpn hoste dürfte man ja von
außen bei mir drauf kommen solange ich eine ipv4 von denen kriege ja ja wenn du brauchst
den ipv4 endpunkt ja das geht geht aber einfacher du brauchst du musst du brauchst du nicht mal
einen vpn zu machen du kannst du einfach eine ssh verbindung machen mit port weiterleitung
aus gar kein vpn was ssh port weiterleitung post kein vpn also wenn das alles ist was du haben
willst dann sagst du dann musst du irgendwie sinngemäß sowas sagen ssh minus g minus remotes
port 8080 auf 192 168 1.1 slash 18 irgendwie sowas und dann blubb blubb.de was auch immer
deine domain ist also domain hast oder irgendwie die die externe ip von deiner vm so müsste das
funktionieren es kann sein dass super dass du ssh global port weiterleitung einschalten muss
das geht also dass das würde dir reichen da brauchst du keinen extra vpn bauen und nachdem
du dir eine linux kiste holst ist das wahrscheinlich bessere variante also meine du brauchst ja einen
internen endpunkt auch und sei es nur der gleiche server wo es wo was läuft ja ja genau das kannst
du damit machen kannst du kein ding kannst du machst ein ssh tunnel da brauchst kein vpn wenn
du kannst auch du kannst auch einen vpn machen ja wenn du mehrere sachen wobei mehrere sachen geht
du musst du musst ja schon explizit explizit ports weiterleiten ja das ist korrekt das ist
richtig nur tcp packages aber das sollte ja das meiste sein ja aber von der idee her funktioniert
das du brauchst halt ein public endpoint und irgendeine kiste bei dir lokal wo drauf das läuft
und dann musst du halt meine vpn alleine reicht ja noch nicht wirklich du musst natürlich gucken
wie die ports dann darüber weiterleiten aber aber prinzipiell ja kann man das damit machen
ich würde wahrscheinlich ein ssh tunnel machen das deutlich einfacher und minecraft multiplayer
ist doch bestimmt tcp based oder hat monkaS in php der xim airworker der war auch schon lange
nicht mehr da lange nicht gesehen hier minecraft modgis hat er am start und ist immer noch voll
dabei ja meine augen github ist immer noch da wie jetzt ach so ja aber dein arbeitgeber ist echt
komisch drauf oder also ich meine du darfst nicht google benutzen du darfst nicht github benutzen
ihr habt noch nicht mal geht ihr benutzt keine gescheiten ide ist keine gescheiten frameworks
was ist warum eigentlich was ist das für einen laden warum warum heißen die so sagt mir nix
also peiper nutzen sagt mir sagt mir nix das php
naja aber ganz ehrlich in unternehmen was die leute nicht ins internet lässt zum googeln
erwarte doch nicht dass die irgendwie gescheite sachen auf die reihe bekommen kannst du aus dem
kopf nicht alles wissen du musst permanent googeln 40 prozent 40 50 prozent der zeit ist googeln
alles selbst gebaut kannst nicht nach google ja aber zumindest mal wie man in der sprache ja
schon recht verstehe ich ja ab ist er ätzend willkommen in der steinzeit anscheinend sieht
man gerade im chat ja das ist echt steinzeit angesagt bei vielen ja sucht euch was anderes
ernsthaft er arbeitet bei google und deswegen darf er google nicht benutzen klingt logisch ja
ups jetzt habe ich ein bisschen wasser verschwendet ok mal kurz gucken ob ich
den lappen hab ja hier exzellent naja leute also unsere php unser php ausflug war jetzt
beschränkt erfolgreich ja okay ja es ist aber schon ein bisschen old school wenn man
nicht mal mehr 2023 geht verwenden kann hat sie auch nicht ohne grund durchgesetzt was ist das
von 2016 what the fuck bist du bei google er hat nicht gedacht dass google so ein so ein
akt man ist näher da die tv bei google muss es doch halbwegs an angenehm sein irgendwas zu
entwickeln ok es würde vielleicht erklären warum youtube so kaputt ist chrome oder stelle ich mir
tatsächlich ganz angemessen stelle ich mir tatsächlich ganz angenehm vor ich meine bei
mir auf der arbeit bin ich dazu gezwungen muss dir mal vorstellen dass ich windows benutzen
muss und total zugekleistert das windows du bootest das ding und hast erst mal 20 icons
in der taskleiste von antivirus und sonst was wer ist selbstverständlich ist wsl deaktiviert
was glaubst du denn aber ich habe es mittlerweile ganz gut hingekriegt ich habe cloud linux vm oder
linux vm auf der ich rote rechte habe und mit der mache ich alles das einzige was ich auf
meinem notebook laufen habe ist fullscreen fullscreen terminal fertig ne das wissel das
wissel studio code terminal gut kann ich mir schon vorstellen wenn man wirklich alles ins
gleiche repo schmeißt ich weiß nicht ob da auch noch viele binaries und sowas drin sind dann wird
es natürlich und vor allem wenn sich dann auch noch an diesen sachen öfters was ändert dann
wird das mit geht schwierig bei uns auch so ich habe mir wie gesagt also ich würde ich würde
anfälle kriegen wenn ich die windows kiste wirklich benutzen müsste was drauf zu machen so
als reines ding wo ein terminal drauf läuft ist es okay ich merke auch schon ich habe auch letzte
teamrunde wieder gemeckert ich habe gesagt leute überlegt euch ich kenne übrigens auch einige
entwickler bei uns die das sagen dass sie gerne linux hätten und bisher interessiert es da keinen
aber ich werde weiter nerven ich werde es bei jeder gelegenheit wenn es probleme gibt oder
zu kompliziert ist wäre ich ein bisschen windows flame und sagen ja würde ich halt mal linux
kriegen wenn das entscheidet ja das ist glaube ich schwierig zu sagen also mein chef alleine
entscheidet es definitiv nicht also schon mal gar nicht für die entwickler das ist eher so eine
policy sache bei uns dass irgendjemand sich die mühe machen muss und das quasi offiziell
beantragen und dann wird das ey leute das bei uns linux workstations zu unterstützen das ist
das ist eine lebensaufgabe nicht auf meinem nicht auf meinem offiziell gestellten notebook ich
arbeite schon den ganzen tag auf linux aber das notebook was ich gestellt bekomme ist windows
ja natürlich auf linux könnte ich mir beispielsweise einfach aus dem package manager
das installieren was ich brauche was ich bei mir auf dem notebook nicht machen kann aber auf
meiner vm glücklicherweise aber ist docker drauf da ist nichts drauf sinnvolles auf der auf der
windows kiste ich benutze die windows kiste rein als terminal für meine meine linux vm ich habe
eine linux vm auf der habe ich hut rechte und ich habe dann terminal im fullscreen auf und
so ist auch immer so ein punkt wenn manche in ihre stellen anzeigen reinschreiben würden freie
betriebssystem auswahl wenn sie sowas haben ist auch für einige leute ein großer pluspunkt also
ich fände das auf jeden fall gut wenn man das gleich wenn man damit wirbt weil das für mich
heißt okay ich kann so arbeiten wie es mir am besten gefällt so schätzchen also ganz ehrlich
mir wäre chrome chromo es auch lieber als windows ja das verstehe ich halt immer nicht die machen
immer den riesen aufriss für fünf leute brauchst du das nicht und die fünf leute die e produktions
rechte haben um dort alles runterzufahren den kann man doch auch zutrauen dass die ihr eigenes
linux system verwalten ich war mehr kaputt machen als sich in der live umgebung einzuladen und dort
die festplatten zu löschen kann ja auch nicht passieren also wenn es einer wirklich mutwillig
was zerstören will dann bestimmt nicht mit dem linux und geht das nicht nur mit dem notebook ja
ist auch so ist auch so ist auch so also sprich das muss dann alles ganz genau dokumentiert sein
warum das warum wie was verwendet wird die haben sich sogar schon aufgeregt ihr müsst euch das
mal vorstellen kubernetes helm install da kam dann jemand um die ecke und hat gemeint was ist das
für eine software die ist aber nicht freigegeben da wollten die ernsthaft erzählen die leute dürfen
nichts mit helm installieren weil helm nicht freigegeben ist das ist wirklich also was das
angeht ist der laden echt hyper pp gehalten ja naja kommen bei ls bei ls hast du doch schon mal
kein rollback verfahren wie ist das rollback verfahren bei ls ganz furchtbar gefährliche
software also in meinem letzten vorstellungsgespräch wurde ich auch ein paar so typische personal
dinger gefragt so was müssten wir machen um sie so richtig zu ärgern zu ärgern und sowas wo wo sehen
sie sich in fünf jahren irgendwie sowas das war aber lustig das war aber lustig wurde wurde der
hat irgendwie gemeint ja und so eine frage die er immer fragt und da habe ich zu ihm gesagt so
lassen sie mich lassen sie mich ran wo sehen sie sich in fünf jahren ja genau nein bitte nicht die
08 15 frage schlechthin aber darüber gekackt eine runde und dann war auch gut was sind ihre
schwächen naja ehrlich ehrlich so richtig ehrlich antworten in einem vorstellungsgespräch ist halt
immer so eine sache wenn du sagst meine schwäche sind leute die dumme fragen stellen das kannst
du ja neben in der situation nicht machen dann denkt ihr irgendwas aus was eigentlich für dich
als etwas für dich eigentlich ehren also nein umgekehrt was eigentlich eher nach vorteil aussieht
du kannst du könntest zum beispiel sowas sagen wie ja wenn ich wenn ich erst mal angefangen habe
mich mit irgendeinem problem auseinanderzusetzen dann dann lasse ich mich gar nicht mehr davon
abbringen und was auch immer denkt ihr irgendwie so blödsinn aus also ich ich würde wahrscheinlich
sagen ich habe ich habe aber auch war deswegen ist es so eigentlich eine ganz gute antwort ich
habe so eine schwäche was das angeht und zwar ich habe meistens relativ genaue vorstellungen wie ich
was ordentlich finde beziehungsweise wie ich denke dass das die richtige art und weise ist wie was
betrieben werden soll und ich lasse mich da immer schwer von abbringen solche fragen dienen oftmals
gar nicht so sehr dem eigentlichen erkenntnis gewinnen was sagt er denn sondern eher so wie
wie reagiert er denn auch so ein bisschen schwierige frage aber das ist immer ist es
immer cringe so ein wenig ich hatte letztens ein vorstellungsgespräch technik welche programmier
sprachen nutzen sie in ihrem beruf ja moment das da hätte ich das sagt ihr mir das doch was mache
ich denn hier laut ihrer laut ihrer stellenanzeige suchen sie leute die keine ahnung ja ja war und
dings und sonst was können was versuchen sie denn so nicht das oder wie bwl fragen das klingt auch
schon das ist nicht nur in deutschen unternehmen so das ist international teilweise noch krasser
was sie dafür blödes zeug fragen oder oder wenn du pech hast musst du dich auch an die tafel stellen
und dann den beine retrieven zu den klassikern ja gut das hat das habe ich ja auch gesagt dass
also dass das habe ich tatsächlich so das habe ich tatsächlich so gesagt allerdings nicht auf
diese frage sondern ich wurde im vorstellungsgespräch gefragt was müssten sie was müssten wir machen um
sie so richtig zu ärgern habe ich gesagt windows administrieren ja schickt die stellen aber hier
moment bevor du dir schickst überlegt ihr das nicht dass sie das zufälligerweise sehen wenn
wenn wir hier ein bisschen flame über die aber sonst schickt schickt mal rüber ich gucke mir das
an wir haben wir haben noch wir haben noch 20 minuten zeit das passt schon ich musste für mein
vorstellungsgespräch für die ausbildung sogar was kleines programmieren ok krass ups was musstest
du denn programmieren für den für den physik ausbildungs ausbildungsbetrieb ausbildungsberuf
das kann ja nur was kleines gewesen mal viel über großartig hello world kann das ja nicht
rausgehen man muss ja eigentlich also man muss von wie soll ich sagen von azubis er würde ich
jetzt eigentlich nicht erwarten dass die schon super krasse vorkenntnis haben ich meine wenn
es einer hat könnte ich es vielleicht durchaus auch mal vorstellungs mit demonstrieren zu lassen
gerade wenn er damit groß angibt aber ansonsten wäre das für mich nicht so ja okay das ist ja
hatte ich nicht gab es nicht würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr machen die
leute ich hatte drei stunden vorstellungsgespräch das hat sich wirklich echt hingezogen aber es war
gut weil gut meine erste sache war eigentlich wir sind die geilste firma auf der welt und
was haben sie bisher so gemacht und bla bla bla dann ging so ein bisschen so diese sachen mit
stärken und schwächen und typisches typisches vorstellungsgespräch talk und am ende ging es
darum dass wir uns einig sind und dann was ich an kohle haben will und dann waren wir uns einig
und haben gleich gesagt wir schicken wir schon vorläufigen vertrag drei stunden oder knapp drei
stunden ging das zwar eigentlich nur auf nur auf zwei angesetzt aber gegen drei weil eigentlich
haben wir uns am anfang darüber darauf verständigt wir können heute noch nix genau entscheiden was
ich auch persönlich gut fand weil ich hatte ja schon anderen vertrag vorliegen und ohne ohne
pause nonstop aber es war halt auch so weil wir nicht fertig geworden sind da war ich auch ein
bisschen mit dran schuld ich meine ich habe ja auch ein paar sachen gefragt und wollte noch ein
bisschen erzählen so war eigentlich gar nicht schlecht und normalerweise hatten wir uns eigentlich
darauf geeinigt wir entscheiden uns heute noch nicht wir wollen danach jeder jeder seite will
danach noch mal kurz überlegen aber wir haben uns dann so gut verstanden nach zwei stunden dass wir
gesagt haben weißt du was wir machen das gleich und dann muss man es halt auch noch um gehalt und
alles unterhalten normalerweise hätte man das bei einer zweiten runde gemacht dann wir haben das
alles in einer runde gemacht und dann hatte ich dann hatte ich den vertrag in der post paar tage
später es ging wirklich sehr schnell halt alles noch vorläufig weil ich es muss ja auch schnell
gehen weil wie gesagt ich muss ja den anderen den anderen die mir schon den ich eigentlich schon
quasi zugesagt hatte wo ich den vertrag schon hier auf dem tisch liegen hat den muss ich ja noch
absagen leute das war mir echt peinlich ihr könntet ihr könnte wahrscheinlich sagen muss
einem nicht peinlich sein aber naja mir war es ein bisschen peinlich es war eine blöde situation
ja den mit den anderen hatte ich schon zwei vorstellungsgespräche geführt wir haben uns haben
uns gut verstanden die haben ja schon vertrag geschickt wir waren uns mit allem einig und da
muss ich dann halt anrufen und sagen ja hat sich doch was anderes ergeben ich stehe nicht mehr
zur verfügung und ich habe mich dann übrigens gedrückt davor ich habe dann dort angerufen da
war die die frau von der personalabteilung mit der ich die ganze zeit zu tun hatte war gerade
nicht da da habe ich dort angerufen hat mit jemand anderem geredet und ob er das nicht ausrichten kann
hat ausgerichtet dann war gut und danach habe ich noch schriftlich abgesagt per mail ja war
schon ein bisschen unangenehm ja aber letztendlich was willst du machen das andere angebot war
einfach besser einfach ghosten ja nee das ist das ist nix das würde ich nicht machen ok also
zeigt mal her anwendungsentwickler betriebsführung systeme oder es klingt so ein bisschen nach nach
bahn oder sowas sie möchten sich verändern und weiterentwickeln ich will einfach nur geld
verdienen diese fragen immer am anfang von solchen stellen anzeigen ich will nicht unter
der brücke schlafen ich brauche geld sie möchten sich verändern oder und weiterentwickeln nun kann
man kann diese position genau das richtige für sie sein für die lausitz energie bergbau ag suchen
wir zwei anwendungsentwickler betriebsführung systeme mwd männlich weiß deutsch wie immer
für den bereich it und geschäftsprozesse ja das finde ich aber sie das würde ich nicht machen
unsere mitarbeiter sind unser wertvollstes kapital wir suchen eine soll mich das jetzt
irgendwie davon überzeugen dass sie wir suchen eine motivierte unterstützt von der team mit
den die leute die sowas schreiben das sind halt einfach so floskeln ich glaube die denken sich
da überhaupt nichts bei wir suchen eine motivierende unterstützung für unser team mit
gestaltungswillen wir bieten verantwortungsvolle aufgaben in einem modernen respektvollen in einem
modernen respektvollen arbeitsumfeld und hervorragende weiterbildungsmaßnahmen dabei
ist uns auch das thema work life balance sehr wichtig mobiles arbeiten ist möglich ist schon
mal gut mobiles arbeiten ist möglich heißt auch home office ist möglich nur die frage in welchem
als anwendungsentwickler dw moment wie keine männer ich fühle mich ausgegrenzt spielen sie
eine wichtige rolle bei der unterstützung der geschäftsprozesse bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla okay der schwerpunkt liegt auf der beratung unserer fachabteilung zum einsatz von attil und
bei der durchführung von entwicklungsaufgaben sowie auf der gesamtverantwortung moment was
du bist anwendungsentwickler bist du bist du berater du bist berater du bist entwickler
und du machst den betrieb auch noch oder wie oder was oder weitere aufgaben das reicht noch nicht
weitere aufgaben werden sein beraten der fachabteilung mit fokus auf den geschäftsprozessen
was du bist anwendungsentwickler okay den zusammenhang kann ich jetzt nicht kann ich
jetzt nicht nicht herstellen ehrlich gesagt was das eine mit was die stellenanzeige mit
diesem aufgabengebiet zu tun hat erfassung und dokumentieren von anforderungen erstellen von
lasten und pflicht nerven ja okay durchführbarkeitsanalysen aufwandschätzung für
umsetzung ja okay aber aber sollte die hauptaufgabe eines anwendungsentwicklers
nicht tatsächlich sein sachen zu entwickeln steuern von steuern von entwickler und bist
du jetzt auch noch teamleiter oder wie dabei durchführung von ja das ist so die hauptaufgabe
eigentlich second level support für anwendung übernahme der itsm rolle system manager sind
die noch sind die noch bei trost oder was wissens- und know-how-management leiten von
kleinen und mittleren projekten was zum teufel ist das für eine anzeige wer auch immer die
geschickt hat bist du wirklich sicher dass du dahin willst ich meine es sei denn die bezahlen
wirklich gut ja applikations spezifische also sie müssen die schon mal 100k plus ja
applikations spezifische zuarbeiten an zentrale it projekte ihr profil als anwender sie besitzt
okay bla bla bla bla ihre kenntnisse verschiedener webtechnologien erfahrung mit
itil prozessen im projekt management was zum teufel du chaotix das kann tatsächlich deutlich
besser sein als die stellenanzeige jetzt aussieht die stellenanzeige ist echt kompletter shit aber
das muss nicht wirklich auf das unternehmen zutreffen weil du hast wir wissen jetzt nicht
wie diese stellenanzeige entstanden ist aber ich meine die fragen sollten aber im
vorstellungsgespräch schon gestattet sein sowie dass dann alles zu einem anwendungsentwickler
job passt also was du was sie jetzt eigentlich genau von dir wollen weil die anforderungen hier
sind halt nicht so sehr entwickler anforderungen und und ist ja auch sehr breit gefächert und und
wir ja das würde ich alles ein bisschen netter formulieren aber das sollten sie schon mal
erklären im vorfeld ich glaube auch die die personalabteilung das geschrieben hat einfach
kein plan was sie da schreibt sehr gute programmierkenntnisse und mehrere erfahrungen zum
beispiel sie schafft und net java html css und relationalen datenbank oracle sql mysql
msql ja also ich würde es mir an deiner stelle trotzdem mal anhören wenn es bei dir in der
gegend nicht so viele alternativen gibt aber es ist also die stellenanzeige ist wirklich mies
zusammenarbeit teamarbeit ja gut breitschaft zum lernen übernahm verantwortung kommunikation
verständnis von verständnis von kaufmännischen produktionsnahen prozessen das englisch
ausgeprägte analysefähigkeit hohes maß an plan also die stellenanzeige ist wirklich
müll ganz ehrlich was nicht heißt dass das unternehmen ist aber die stellenanzeige ist
müll moment das soll auch noch für berufs ein moment moment ist das chaotix ist das eine
einstiegsstelle also das kann ich dir in ernstheit oder wie viel erfahrung hast du schon und also
mit wie viel jahren bewirbst du dich da mehrjährige erfahrung mit dem schwerpunkt anwendungsentwicklung
und prozesse also ganz ehrlich ziemliche ppg anzeige haben wir ihr interesse geweckt ehrlich
gesagt nicht also die anzeige ist wirklich äußerst ppg ghosting wenn bewerber kommentare
aus dem bewerbungsprozess aussteigen früher haben es unternehmen gemacht das recht sich nun ja das
kann ich mir gut vorstellen ja also wie gesagt ich habe die nicht gegossen ich habe einfach
abgesagt ich finde das finde das auch blödsinnig also ganz ehrlich das wird das das will ich nicht
dass das bei mir im bewerbungsprozess gemacht wird so nach dem motto wir melden uns nie wieder und
ich finde das auch nicht auch nicht fair gerade wenn es also sollte das ein kackladen sein ja
dann kann man sich das überlegen aber die waren ja nicht schlecht sonst hätte ich ja gar nicht
daran gedacht da eigentlich anzufangen also dann dann poste ich die auch nicht sondern
sag halt einfach ab ja aber das ist das ist doch egal die haben ihn doch eingeladen das hat dass
sie geht doch aus seinem lebenslauf hervor und sie haben ihn trotzdem eingeladen allein schon
deswegen kann man sagen ja okay aber ich sitze ja hier wie üblich ist wie üblich ist second level
support für anwendungsentwickler selten zumindest was ich von unseren entwicklern jetzt mitbekomme
und eine alten firma mitbekommen hat also in der alten firma sogar noch weniger aber second level
support dass du als anwendungsentwickler wirklich wirklich kontakt hast mit irgendwelchen entweder
endanwendern äußerst selten hätte ich auch überhaupt kein bock drauf ja die wollen die
wollen es anscheinend aber auch nicht anders oder also mein da muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die
leute schon was neues haben warum sagst du dir nicht einfach ab jetzt ernsthaft warum sagst du
dir nicht einfach ab hat es einen grund also ich will ich will ich nicht schlecht willst du ich
ausreden du kannst machen was du willst auch wenn ich es nicht ich so nice finde von dir aber mein
hat ja vielleicht eine gründe also warum warum sagst du dir nicht einfach ab hat es irgendeinen
grund kann kann sein weil es jetzt nicht mehr magst ans trinken erinnern ja ich habe ich habe
relativ viel gesoffen hier schon dabei ich habe die ganze wasserflasche leer getrunken während
dem streben normalerweise sollte da ein ordentlicher fehler fehlerbericht aufgemacht werden und die
hotline sollte schon irgendwas erstellen in der richtung dass dass es nicht oft vorkommt dass man
als entwickler direkt mit anwendern telefonieren muss ja gut wenn die wenn die frech wenn die frech
schreiben so nach dem motto also du hast die haben interesse an dir aber du hast absolut kein bock
dahin zu gehen verstehe ich richtig ja kann man so machen ich würde den einfach absagen ja kannst
sagen du verfolgst jetzt andere andere was auch immer irgendwie lasst ihr chat gpt eine absage
generieren ist doch heute kein ding das stimmt aber in zeiten von homeoffice und remote arbeit
hast du durchaus auch chancen woanders zu arbeiten als du wohnst muss doch nicht also es gibt ja
durchaus unternehmen die lassen sich auf remote arbeit ein muss doch nicht mal zwangsläufig
deutsches unternehmen sein aber gibt es auch da ein paar manche sagen auch ok hauptsächlich remote
arbeit aber einmal im monat sollte das gesamte team vor ort sein das kann man sich ja dann
tatsächlich überlegen weil einmal im monat kann man ja durchaus mal zwei stunden zug hin zwei
stunden zug zurückfahren oder sowas oder vielleicht sogar einmal übernachten nach dem was es ist wenn
sich halt lohnt es muss sich unterm strich lohnen aber man hat heute halt viel mehr möglichkeiten
dank remote arbeit und homeoffice ja dann würde ich einfach vier stunden zugfahrt das würde ich
nicht machen würde ich einfach sagen und tschüss aber in dem vorstellungsgespräch sieht es also
bei der bewerbung sieht es doch schon mal ganz anders aus sie suchen ja explizit leute dann
oder wenn du dich da bewirbst suchst du dir explizit welche wo eben remote arbeit möglich
homeoffice mit der redet man im vorfeld schon drüber wenn man sagt hier ich wohne da und da
ich habe mich jetzt hier beworben und ihr sucht ja auch leute mit riemann wenn man sich dann einig
ist dann ist doch klar wieder die verhältnisse sind und wenn dann einer ankommt mit ah du musst
jetzt doch jeden tag ins büro da ist man wieder weg er steuern bezahlen kommst du nicht drumherum
leider naja das ist das ist aber schwer das ist schwer zu halten ich meine ich habe ich habe
wirklich einen super arbeitsweg ja ich wohne hier schräg gegenüber vom bahnhof quasi und muss
einsteigen also bei mir ist es sogar aber auch über eine halbe stunde wenn ich wirklich mal
dann auch das laufen vom hauptbahnhof zum zum zum büro und somit einbeziehen da würde ich sagen bin
ich auch eher so eher so 40 minuten einfach unterwegs und meine strecke ist wirklich easy
und das ist auch nur wenn die bahn mit spielt also halbe stunde ist wirklich sehr knapp bemessen
ist aber auch nicht wild weil ich arbeite halt also ich arbeite nur vier tage die woche und
vor den vier tagen mache ich drei war drei tage homeoffice und einen tag die woche muss
ich nach frankfurt also easy da kann ich das ohne probleme auf mich nehmen da mal ein bisschen
unterwegs zu sein weiß ich ob das ein guter fall ist bei der bahn zu arbeiten ok leute ich gehe
jetzt ins bett wir sehen uns morgen macht's gut bis dann